à Magny-les-Hameaux il est maintenant
possible de recharger son smartphone en
pédalant j'ai plus de batterie dans mon
téléphone enfin j'en ai plus beaucoup
comme j'oublie tout le temps mon
chargeur et la ville a mis en place
récemment des bornes on peut faire du
sport et en même temps changer son
téléphone donc je trouve ça génial
allons tester ça
équipé de deux ports USB ainsi qu'un
chargeur à induction vous pouvez charger
jusqu'à trois appareils en même temps
sur une seule borne pour le moment il y
en a deux sur la peine de chemin court
mais une dernière est prévue près du
skatepark de la ville
bon c'est un peu physique mais au moins
c'est cool parce que là mon téléphone il
charge et en même temps je dépense des
calories donc quoi de mieux j'ai envie
de dire ce service inédit s'accompagne
d'une application il Oba et ludique
énergie elle permet de vous connecter
aux bornes de la ville en Bluetooth et
d'enregistrer votre énergie dépensée une
solution éco-responsable et ludique
contre l'angoisse des batteries
déchargées